hi there steve coffin here today uh i
want to do a number of things i want to
talk about
the sort of fundamental concept
of what what i consider to be a
fundamental concept in learning and that
is repetition and novelty
which manfred spitzer in his book on
learning in the brain refers to and
which certainly has been my experience
in learning so i'm going to get into
that but first of all i want to remind
you first of all to subscribe subscribe
if you enjoy this channel
give this video a like if you like it
and uh thursday we're gonna do a
streaming session
so i will briefly talk about three
subjects and that is number one like how
do you get started like people are
always asking this if how can you listen
and read if you don't understand what
you're listening and reading to
listening to and reading and the second
thing is
how do you cope with you know more than
one language at a time these are
subjects that come up all the time and
the third thing i'll talk about briefly
is you know starting to speak when do we
start to speak how do we start to speak
so i want to talk about those things and
i want to hear your questions and and
your ideas but today i want to talk
about the importance of repetition and
novelty
and i'm doing that for a number of
reasons first of all because
you know as i work around the house and
i have to clean up the garage or
whatever i'm listening to
a lot of the content that i have
listened to many many times in link
by the way i find that listen to the
audio of a course so we have 60 mini
stories at link
in different languages or any of the
courses we have you can listen to the
whole audio
so i go to my
ipod
uh touch
i select that
and so i've got as much listening as i
want because it'll go through the 60
stories
each one of which is about three or four
minutes long and it'll go back to the
first one again and so you know i just
end up listening to hours and hours of
this stuff so i haven't looked recently
how many times i've listened to these
stories but it's 20 30 40 times for sure
however each time i listen i discover
something new so there's a lot of
repetition there the stories are not new
to me and yet i'm discovering a new
tense that i'm vaguely aware and then
now there i see it or a new structure or
a word that i had forgotten and i'm
re-learning and and so i'm getting
something out of it okay
the big advantage with that of course is
that i can be doing other things so you
know the bulk of my learning activity is
listening in fact what i might just do
is is
show you that
um i will i will do um
sort of a loom peek at my statistics
in link and you'll see that i've
listened to almost 80 hours over the
last two months i've been at turkish now
for the last two months i've listened to
80 hours most of that is while doing
other tasks most of it is repetitive and
yet each time i'm discovering something
new
uh you will see that i've read i can't
remember 120 000 words a lot of that 2
is reading for the second time yet i am
also i go and have a peek at link to
what other people are studying
and i'll go in there sometimes and
discover an interesting new course i'm
also introducing some novelty
and
that sort of combination of repetition
and novelty is what enables us to learn
i had a brief exchange on twitter with a
teacher
who thinks it's very important in
reading to ask questions like
comprehension questions and so forth and
so on i'm totally against that because
if you were to ask me a question after
the first time that i listened to some
of these stories i i didn't understand
what happened and and i'm going to
listen again or if you asked me a
grammar question you know
choose the correct case or the correct
tense i wouldn't be able to do that and
and i don't really want to be tested
immediately i just want to get that into
me get that repetition going and rely
more on
the natural ability of the brain to
learn things
when we combine some new things
with some repetition rather than
relying on the brain trying to
reconstruct what it thought it heard and
it got it wrong and and so i just rely
on repetition and novelty
now that ties into this idea of learning
several languages at the same time
because right now i'm focusing on
turkish but i don't want to slip too
badly
in arabic and persian i'm allowing greek
and romanian and those to slip we'll get
back to those later
however because i'm kind of going after
these three languages as a combined
project i don't want to slip too much in
these other languages so again to
introduce novelty i i tend to leave my
link ipad activities sort of dedicated
to turkish and my listening is dedicated
to turkish but because i also happen to
have
asimil
and in both persian and arabic
then i uh treat myself to going over
both of these assimil courses from the
beginning
various times it could be before going
to bed it could be at various times
during the day now i'm just reading so
it's a different in that sense it's kind
of novel it's a different i'm not
reading on the ipad i'm not clicking on
words i'm reading stuff that i have done
before that i've heard many times but
i'm going at it again
i'm discovering things that i have
forgotten
and as i've also pointed out when we
learn forget and relearn we are in fact
learning
better so that introduces a sort of a
an element of novelty in my learning but
my main focus
is on on turkish and my main strategy is
this focus on uh repetition repetitive
listening and yet
mixing into that
new material and i'll show you as i say
when i have a look at what i'm doing on
link you can have a look i'll use loom
to to illustrate that so that's really
what i wanted to say now i have heard
the complaint that my rambling talks
here are boring because they always go
over the same ground which they do
because these are things that i'm
passionate about
however it's just possible
that by me repeating the same themes
in a slightly different way each time
that there is a process there of
repetition and novelty
that might be helpful to people because
very often if we have something
explained to us once
we get some of it which is fine and i
don't think we should be obliged to
answer questions about what we just
heard
but if we then cover that same material
in a slightly different way
that reinforces the learning i found
that when i was studying at university
if i would
just stick to the textbook i'd only get
one version of whatever the subject was
whereas i would go out and find
you know books on related subjects and
read
the these and that would reinforce what
i had learned rather than trying to nail
down what was in the textbook so
hopefully these rambling and somewhat
repetitive
videos that i make are
you know helpful maybe you discover
something new that might encourage you
uh each time
uh or it might just reinforce
what your understanding was the first
time and this is especially true
for people whose mother tongue is not
english so
and there's many different uh listeners
who listen for very many different
reasons all right don't forget thursday
we have our streaming
and also i'm hoping you will go to
long fest in montreal you can look it up
l-a-n-g-f-e-s-t long fest in montreal
i'll leave a link here in the
description box if you enroll with my
name steve lower case uppercase doesn't
matter you will get a discount i will be
there it'll be a great opportunity for
people interested in languages to get
together bye for now
yeah just uh
to show you a little bit
about what i have been doing
so if i look at the last 30 days here i
am in my words of reading you'll see
that
i was reading more earlier and now i'm
doing more listening i do read i do a
lot of this reading is rereading old
text i'm sort of
because i've read all the mini stories
and stuff that's kind of at my level
uh i'm struggling a bit to find
interesting stuff that's kind of at my
level and so i'm speaking more with
tutors
because that gives me the tutor report
which is very useful
for providing me with content to read
and and to listen to
on vocabulary that's of interesting to
me interest to me you know words that i
want to use to express the things that
we're talking about but in talking to
the tutors i realized that my
grasp on the grammar is not where i
would like it to be in order to talk
with my tutors so i'm focusing more sort
of doubling back onto the many stories
and simple material to get a better
grasp
of that now
again repetition versus novelty so i'm
improving my grasp uh and my ability to
speak but i am
you know giving up so words of reading
is there if we look at uh you know
listening hours
uh
that hasn't declined so i'm doing a lot
of listening
uh
also if we look at uh you know uh
words uh where are known words for
example
here again it's uh i mean it's
increasing but it's not increasing at
the same rate as before so
uh all of this sort of you have to
decide where you want to spend your time
if you wanted more repetition
uh to improve your grasp on something
but after a while you're learning less
and less and the repetition is lose is
wearing off the benefits or you're
investing in the long term
improving increasing your vocabulary
but then
i find there i struggle more in my
conversation so
this is a matter of choice at different
times in different languages i have
chosen to focus more on acquiring
vocabulary and getting used to the
language
by attacking more and more new material
or at times for whatever reason i'm
motivated to do better in my speaking
with my tutors in which case i spend
more time reviewing stuff that i have
already done to get a better grasp
on that material both in terms of
vocabulary and grammar so just a little
peek into my account here to reinforce
what i was talking about having to do
with repetition and novelty
you